walk out to this video playing car acero
again I just had played him in this
complicated way mmm can maybe come on
let's play a very classical set up here
just just developing nothing fancy yeah
let's let's prevent b5 come on just a
simple positional game you know Bishop
age 6 I still like to play get rid of
this Bishop be 6 mm don't know okay how
is he going to castle now maybe maybe
isn't
ah he's dead supposing to a benoni type
of structure
wait i'm thinking about 55 e6 that's
probably not so great
wait wait still still come on let's
let's calculate for once just for once
e5c be 4e takes f6 can take you three
others this is not good okay takes f6
takes you three added sets indeed not
good okay come on let's do that it's
it's just leaning to a better structure
for white some need to be content with
that for the moment of course the Queen
on d to woman this is normally a place
for the night but preventing castles is
not bad at all how to how to get ahead
though maybe maybe we'll their form
gaining space we'll wait wait wait wait
let's let's prevent see form need to be
alert you don't need to allow I'm
counterplay maybe you can play something
like esox or you five but ok this is for
faded this idea with the knight on d5
yes yeah I was thinking about this
briefly and some may be an option ok i
can probably maneuver the night to g3
looking at this crucial at five squared
you don't want to take on d5 really wow
yeah this is basically giving away their
five square it's it's it's a gaping hole
now very difficult now for black he
needs to play Bishop CA probably back to
cover that and then I'll go F for
opening up the position anyway it's a
skin going maybe you should I shoot
Castle long even as lucky as it looks
yep but there five is a great square
and I mean the king I can I can play
group we want it before that's not out
of the question at all yeah I don't
really want to go F for him I mean this
would have been nice if he had castled
if he had Castle short but he hasn't
maybe I should just go here young yeah
protect d5 and prepare Queenie to
attacking a 6 it keeps my pawn in
protected here yeah okay of course I
don't want to open the position
maybe you can try to move the night and
then play a 5 yeah something like that
I'm not sure this is good but I didn't
want to invest time Jan how does he yeah
but this is an open bihar now I hope
leading to an attack night at five and I
want to get out of out of this hmm
should I go come on he needs to react to
the vporn threat anyway I guess I don't
think he can take age five and allow the
caption droopy one is such a big threat
mmm so a five should have form their own
all nice yeah I'd like to play the sugar
form but queen bee three also would be
good yeah we can double on the befall
simple chess it's a simple and it's I
think it's strong one minute 29
yeah I'm just throwing throwing dirt at
me hoping to induce some blunder okay
I'll check HERE Prague Czech threatening
on d6 check
come on rock t 6 this is deadly knock or
not it really should be black resigned
yeah it is it is yeah yeah this is
opening was a bit too much I think it
what was it was placing very heavy
obligations of black he came out castle
and it's a it's tricky he must we must
play g5 as he did and otherwise he's
never going to Castle but I think what
was really really bad is this idea to
give me the five square and then when he
was covering it but it was just trading
one problem for the other yeah I with a
comp gives night takes h5 tactic I was
briefly considered about the data this
loose night but I didn't see the tactic
Jim could have done that okay where this
means that Queenie to was was mistimed
yeah well there are many good good moves
I mean I can Bishop c4 let's say this
was a bad idea i can go back and just
play rugby one end before black is going
to explode in the long run this scheme
position is and is not not simply
unbearable yeah this is this plus 2 with
this position for example for the comp
yeah that's set just 22 better position
alright thanks for watching